but don't worry okay steady pass that
means I ought to talk about stuff now so
hello
um I there's a link to my website in the
event that anyone has any interest in
speaking to me again uh there's links to
my Twitter and all the rest of it so if
at the end of this you have questions uh
at least one's about about programming
my mum still has the rest of those
questions she's been pondering those for
the last 40 years but
um
yeah feel free to reach out
so
getting going briefly about me I'm not
going to go through all of this I've
been in it an awfully long time now it's
coming on two decades I really am that
old
um I I've worked in a whole load of
different
um uh different sectors I've done
gatherment and made sure that you folks
all pay your taxes hey
um I've done
manufacturing retail these days I was
briefly one of those contractors that
your mum used to warn you about and
these days I work for Muller as in
corner I am told at some point I'll be
given some free yogurt but it hasn't
materialized yet so Liam when he watches
this video later
uh but anyway that's enough about me
this is my program of events I like
films so I have a program of events you
see uh this is and I'm going with the
slightly inaccurately named uh sixws who
what where when why and how a functional
programming that's that's that's my uh
that's my structure for my talk
so first off who is it these are a
couple of individuals who are
significant to the history of functional
programming one of them is a developer
see if you can guess which one uh this
gentleman though is a mathematician his
name is Alonso Church uh he's
significant to us for a couple of
reasons mostly down to this Lotto down
here which I'm not going to pretend I
entirely understand because I am not a
mathematician caveat going in I am not a
mathematician but here we go it's an
arrow this is a shorthand way of
describing a function in mathematics
it's an arrow function there you go
thanks to him and over here
that there that's the Greek letter
Lambda which donates a parameter hence
Lambda expression that's where they come
from uh this was from the 1950s as well
so this man is um Haskell Curry who has
no fewer than three programming
languages named after him including
rather famously Haskell uh and this is
one of his other contributions here this
is an example of carrying don't worry
about that at the moment but he wrote
maths papers which serve as an awful lot
of the underpinning of functional
programming
could this be possibly yeah
it is uh this is John McCarthy who
created arguably the first functional
programming language lisp in the 1960s
that is a bit of lisp over there I don't
know what that does either uh apparently
list still has its fans apparently it's
pretty wild apparently you can do
incredible things like rewriting
innumerables as you go or something I
don't know but in any case 1960s and
that's that's how far back it goes
so what is it
not
well the main point of those last few
slides is it is not new in fact
functional programming in some senses
predates object oriented
um it dates back to maths papers which
are written largely in the 50s but I
once wasted a Sunday uh if you can call
it that
um trying to trace how far back that
particular Rabbit Hole really goes and
it a lot of the very first work was late
1800s
so it's really flipping old it is not um
it is not the latest trendy
um JavaScript framework it is not the
latest
um whatever in the development
environment it is really old it predates
Microsoft it predates most programming
languages you're likely to have ever
used
it is not a language in fact
um it's a paradigm now what's a paradigm
well Paradigm is a style of programming
if you want a metaphor then take a
guitar with a guitar you may play many
styles of music on you could play Rock
you could play pop you can play country
and western if you have no soul but you
get the idea
it is a style of programming not in and
of itself a language and it is not
imperative imperative is the common
alternative Paradigm though in fact I I
again this is one of those rabbit holes
I went into there are actually lots and
lots of paradigms but the two Big E's
well the two big families of them are uh
imperative and declarative imperative is
your object-oriented coding and it is
not like that
imperative code is very concerned with
the very precise order of operations
start here go here loop around like this
go here that's an imperative approach
declarative programming is what
functional programming belongs to the
rather more familiar form of declarative
programming to you folks is probably SQL
SQL is declarative
if you think about it you're not
concerned with the order of operations
in tsql or whichever other flavor you
tend to write select and then maybe some
joins somewhere an order by maybe a
group by is that order actually the
order of execution no no it's not quite
often the select's the last thing that's
run not always but often you get the
idea with declarative we are not
concerned with the order of operations
we are more concerned with describing
what we want and then largely leaving
the environment to worry about the
precise way it goes about them
it's not the solution to all of your
problems uh it will not make coffee in
the morning I have tried this it does
not work but I would argue it is the
solution to many of them nor is it
difficult and that's one of the other
ones that gets chucked at functional
programming that it's difficult it's not
it's not difficult at all in fact there
are fewer things to learn in in
functional programming compared to
object oriented if you don't believe me
go and find a non-technical member of
your family and try and explain object
orientation to them try it'll take you a
lot longer than you think you've
probably just been doing this for a
while
um most of the folks that I have
encountered who are uh the keenest to
adopt functional are often folks who are
new to the business who may be fresh out
of University who simply haven't spent
that time getting used to the
um the object-oriented Paradigm and the
folks who tend to be the most resistant
are often those who've spent an awfully
long time and object oriented and don't
really want to shift gears and do
something entirely different but I would
still argue that if you were choosing
Fresh then this is probably the easier
of the two options you've got
no
there we go and what actually is it well
here's all of the properties of
functional programming some of these
have scary names but none of them are
actually all that hard uh it's the
clarity I've already talked about that
so as I say we are not concerned with
the order of operations we are simply
describing and letting the machine get
on with it uh it is it uses immutability
which basically means that once a
variable has been set you may not change
it or any of its properties ever again
basically treat everything as a cast
uh everything or read only or whatever
and all its properties you can't change
it done so stop using lists basically
and a few other things too I'll get on
to that
higher order functions funky name not
really very hard you've probably been
doing it if you've done C sharp for any
amount of time for a while and that is
variables passed around either as the
parameter to a function or as the return
from a function so link if you've done
an arrow functioning link that's what it
is
uh functions not statement so statements
what are those statements are things
which do not actually return anything
um so four four each if while we don't
use them
so this is fun this is programming
without those structures those are uh
imperative structures
referential transparency also called
Pure functions so this is the idea that
given the same set of parameters a
function will always to return the same
result no matter what
no matter the life of the universe no
matter the state of a system accepting
that you you know turn the computer off
other than that given these parameters
you will always get this result uh it's
called reference it's called a
referential transparency because
effectively you can just switch the
reference of the function with the
parameters for the actual value
or something but anyway uh recursion are
we all good on recursion
good gonna be a tough talk for you
otherwise uh pattern matching I used to
have to explain this but I don't these
days since I have been doing this talk
and I've been doing this talk about four
or five years now uh that's pretty much
become a thing in C sharp and this is
good if anyone has played with the
switch Expressions which are there since
what about C sharp six seven I think
um that's pattern matching and every
single version of C sharp that has been
um that's come out has had more pattern
matching in uh even down to uh C sharp
11 it gave us the the as everyone's in
the new the list matching it's our new
one that's pretty cool there is still
further probably to go on it and there
is something called active patterns
which we may or may not get but anyway
pattern matching is definitely a amazing
feature and it's it's there in C sharp
is now it's stateless
there's no concept of State
object-oriented code typically goes by
the idea that you have a state object we
will do a thing and the state object
will sit there and the thing will
periodically ping the state and update
it get it update it get it that's not a
concept in uh functional program we
don't have a state
if anybody has messed with react and has
played with Redux that's roughly the
idea of what we go with it's the um what
you have is a state which exists for the
length of the life of a function
effectively and you change it by having
a function which takes the Old State and
an instruction and then creates new
state so rather than a single state
object We have basically a series of
them that exist for a moment and a
constantly sort of Disappearing and
coming about within a new form uh that's
monads you say those are the ones that
tend to make people's ears bleed if you
try to explain to them uh there's a talk
by Douglas crockford where he says the
curse of the monad is that once you gain
the ability to understand it uh you lose
the ability to explain it
so I shant
and not difficult I hope you'll agree by
the end of the talk
so where is it well it can go anywhere
and I will probably get into trouble
over some of the things I say if there's
any any uh pure functional programming
folks in the crowd today but uh it can
go anywhere it can do anything but there
are places where it is happiest uh and a
better fit if if you're having to
compromise a
well these are the languages there for a
start where you that you can use it so
there's the the pure functional language
or pure I don't think all of these are
necessarily entirely pure but certainly
Haskell is airline's a biggie an Elm I
don't know if anyone's used rabbit mq
that was I think that was Airline so I
believe that is uh
um done with functional programming and
the claim of these languages the
functional ones is that with some of
them that once you actually get the
thing to compile and run nothing will
bring it down like it's rock solid and
can't be can't be defeated brought off
and that might well be true now we're
not entirely going to get that in C
sharp but I would argue that we're
moving closer to that goal by adopting
this approach and I'll show you how
later
as the hybrid languages well C sharp C
sharp is a hybrid language it is a
stated intention of the Microsoft team
that they will support both paradigms I
mean it's true that right at the
beginning it was object oriented only
but these days we're getting close to
having a 50 50 split so you couldn't
just about programming whichever
Paradigm you like there are there are
some fuzzy edges around which you'll
have to compromise but by and large we
can do most of it and that's probably
something that will always continue with
time uh mads Torgerson is a fan of
functional programming and as far as I'm
aware he intends to continue this trend
and on top of that you've also got the F
sharp guys F sharp is the functional
language inside.net and quite often they
will request something for the
Intermediate Language and since they can
part of the same Intermediate Language
there's a good chance that we in the C
sharp world will benefit from that too
so it's probably a process that's not
going to end anytime soon I have not yet
seen much in the way of a spec for C
sharp 12 but I am anticipating it'll
probably be something for a city sharp
12 as well
and yes there's F sharp and JavaScript
well JavaScript supports everything
because JavaScript is everything except
when it isn't because everything in
JavaScript is everything except when it
isn't except when it's an array except
when it's a function except when it's
not a number or something I don't know
because it's the wild west of
programming and it does everything
um JavaScript does functional
programming far better than than we ever
could hope and I have other talks on
this subject uh check out ramda.js if
you want to see some really wild
JavaScript
to when again it can go everywhere it
can do anything but these are the things
it's the most happy at doing as it were
um data processing that is take data
from this form turn it into this it
likes doing that concurrent systems
meaning you've got lots of things
running uh in in parallel because
there's no state if there's no State you
tend not to get resource contention
issues and you'll tend to have a happier
result so if you're interested in stuff
like serverless functions or feeding off
the same queue or or anything of that
sort then functional programming tends
to support you very well
uh High criticality because in general
functional programming is more robust
than the object-oriented alternatives
so if it's very important to you that
this go up and knock them down you might
want to start adopting more functional
programming techniques
and uh serverless that's kind of dates
back ties back to the the idea of the
concurrent systems if you are interested
in the serverless route again this is
probably the some of the things you want
to think about
when is it not now once again I I want
to check my exits but it can do these
things it can indeed but functional
programming is predicated on the idea
that there are it is built up of
functions which are pure that is no side
effects uh no nothing is happening
except data comes in and out you know so
these are places where you have to make
compromises in order to let it happen
um there are all thoughts of options out
there I know certainly Haskell has as a
monad based system for dealing with
these but this is where compromises are
necessary so UI is one because there is
nothing more impure than a human being
um external interactions with other
systems you don't know what's going to
happen when you're when your HTTP
request goes out who knows what happened
was it goes down the wire and it may not
necessarily be your fault
um it probably is though and um and I
have a same sort of idea so you can but
again a compromise is necessary there is
now there are the metaphor I use is that
if you look at a shadow there are plenty
around here if you care to look at one
there are two parts to any Shadow there
is the dark solid part in the middle
that's the Umbra and the gray fuzzy bit
around the edge that is the penumbra uh
and I'm learning drawing I know there's
more than two there's like 12 but two
for the purposes of this metaphor and
um
but that solid bit in the middle is what
I think of is the functional part of the
system I make that as solidly functional
as I can as much of a system as I can
and the places where I have to
compromise I make as small as possible
and push to the fringes of the system
where I worry about them less
nah the big all-important question why
why do I should I even care
um it is concise now you don't always
get that talked up as a reason for the
functional programming being a good idea
but I really like it it is more concise
it's
um it's often up to about half the size
or depending of of the amount of code
written for an object-oriented
alternative I am incredibly lazy and as
such I like typing less stuff uh I like
and it's not only more concise but also
it is more descriptive in part because
it has been compacted down so small to
it is usually easier to tell what on
Earth a function is doing because
there's not all this code noise in the
way which is you know your loops and all
this and your code structure that exists
to to
actually deliver your results with
puncture program we don't have any of
that so we can just we can just write a
quick few lines and get on with it I get
readable there we go extremely testable
now that is one that comes up a lot and
a lot of people like this for it is
again going back to the idea of pure
functions
um you tend to get incredibly consistent
reliable results with functional code
so um it's very easy to unit test
strictly speaking in a pure functional
environment you shouldn't even have
dependency injection and all sorts but
in C sharp World frankly we do but still
it will tend to get you better results
in in a testing scenario enables
concurrency we've discussed that before
more robust kind of talked about that
and it's fun I think it's fun and
hopefully again you guys will agree by
the end of this
so
here is a bit of very much
non-functional code
what does that do you've got five
seconds
nope see it's not how easy is it
and what that's actually trying to do is
um we are taking a CSV file and we're
going to start up a list we are going to
Loop and inside the loop we are going to
do various things we're going to do some
parsing we're going to do a bit of
filtering and that's all fine
um but there's a lot of a lot of lines
of code to do something and you might
even notice here that uh that resharper
is is tugging up my sleeve say hey hey
boss hey I got a good idea
and and that's because it tends towards
more functional code if you follow all
of resharper's suggestions because the
functional oh and also internally if
anyone recognizes these uh these these
titles here you're automatically my
friend because uh those are the um story
titles in the very first series of
Doctor Who from 1963.
there may be references to Doctor Who in
this talk just just warning you because
Doctor Who is cool
um but anyway what would this look like
functionally like that
now try explaining that in five seconds
and it gets an awful lot easier doesn't
it
Point anyone's gonna say that looks like
an awful lot of link that that's an
awful lot of Link
I'll let you in on a little secret link
is functional
link is entirely based around the
functional Paradigm if you're using link
you are doing functional programming
if you think about it
um a select statement does not change
the original
um whatever was there before the
original enumerable it creates a new one
based on the old one
so it is enabling you to immutably
create an array
um
these here higher order functions
you're passing functions in as
parameters again based in the functional
paradigm
so my goal is to effectively put the
whole rest of c-sharp into link
and that's roughly the approach I'm
going for but note also first off this
is a lot more concise it's easier to say
what it does and this more closely
matches
um logically what I want to do in the
order that I want to do these things
logically this is not actually the order
of operations that you see here
innumerables will execute in the order
they feel that they wish to at the time
and may not even execute at all but none
of that really is your concern all
you're doing is describing what you want
in the order you want it as if you were
describing it to another human being
and that's fundamentally I think a good
thing because if you were fresh to
programming and you were presented with
this or this which one are you going to
be able to understand quicker
I'd say this one
are we
oh are we nope
nope stop stop oh
Bob the rise uh there's another bit of
very non-functional code this is
something that I had to deal with an
awful lot back when I worked for hmrc
you're very welcome
um this is the rules for
um uh validating a Nino does anyone
happen to know what a Nino is it
something I had to be very familiar with
at the time it's a national insurance
number
and there are a set of rather esoteric
rules for deciding whether it's a good
Nino or not and it's all to do with
which letters exist in which places is
it an alphanumeric and so on there's a
whole load of them and there's a big
heap of code structure here and a lot of
repeated code structure so we've got
check each rule if the rules doesn't
match then we'll return false if this
rule doesn't match we're going to return
false eventually at the bottom it's
slightly missing off the bottom of the
screen there we'll do a return true at
the end
or we could do something like this
so this is something you can do and I
some I see some people do it but mostly
people don't you can actually put Bank
delegates that is you know your arrow
functions in arrays it's possible
and not only that but then you can apply
link uh link perm functions to them so
um and there we go so this is an array
of funks so that's actually oh they're
all described at the top here you don't
have to put them in separately like but
you know I like that I like the
descriptive name there's nothing wrong
with that that's a matter of choice
these are all turned string to Boom so
take a string return a bull meaning give
me the Nino based on the Nino I will
therefore decide whether it is good or
not in a Boolean and here I am calling a
link or
now what all does is run whatever's
inside here now what I'm actually doing
here is take the Nino and pass it into
the function and then return its result
which is true or false the rule of the
all is that every single one of these
whatever happens in here must return
true if a single one of them doesn't
then stop at that point don't bother to
execute the rest and just return out
early which is a precise replica of the
code on the previous page only I'm doing
it in this much code
oh and you can even take a step further
and do something like this now some
people are down on um down on uh
extension methods I'm not I like them
quite a lot they have their places just
don't be putting any business logic in
there that way Madness lies but uh there
we go so I've extended it to t t being
everything because it's a generic so it
applies to everything and then based on
that t I'm also taking a params of
whatever that was into a bull and it's
paramed just so I don't have to bother
instantiating a new array every time
because I'm just too lazy for that
um and then
will call out all that there we go
so that means that with this teeny tiny
little extension method up here we now
have a function uh call validate which
hangs off everything and then you can
pass it a series of rules one after the
other and that will tell you whether
that thing was valid or not according to
all your rules so again nice and concise
and descriptive you could even show that
to your your non-technical boss and and
the chances are they would understand
what it does even if they couldn't
necessarily maintain it themselves
here's another example of a function
structure this uh I'm calling it alt
here it I've seen it have other names
this is a common theme I found when I've
been digging deeper into this is that
there is no great big bumper Every Kid's
book of functional programming which
gives you literally the definitions of
what everything is and what it's called
it may exist but it's probably a maths
paper in which case I won't read it but
a lot of these things have other names
so the names I use here you might find
the same exact Concepts used elsewhere
with a different name so just be aware
of that but I'm calling it alt and the
idea is that I've got two two functions
which go away and get a thing string to
string in my case it could be anything
now maybe these represent two different
data sources maybe one of them's a
database maybe one of them's a web API
it doesn't really matter they're
actually just funks for the purposes of
the demonstration but you get the idea
and in my case one of them works and one
of them doesn't
you know in object-oriented code you
would need to um and you would try two
different alternative data sources then
you would have to put an if in there
you'd have to do a null check and so on
but here with my ALT all I do is say
here's one item here's the other item
try these one after the other and then
the first one that works you return that
I think the tsql equivalent is a
coalesce I think it's coalesce
um and there we go that's an awful lot
of code I don't need to write in this
case this one does not return it's a
null and if I run this code then this
one would be tried it will find null it
will try this one and this string will
actually be a this works with my name
appended on the end now how does that
work under the surface and it looks like
that
so a couple of extension methods they're
a little messy looking but that's fine
the thing about extension methods is
they are a block of code that I just
want to write them once and then never
care about again they are like the
proverbial snarf action figure from
thundercaps in the 1980s I have it I
don't necessarily want anyone to see it
but I have it
actually I don't I'm lying I never was
never cool enough to have a snuff but um
right what are we doing here so attach
again to a generic meaning attaches to
everything
um and then run Function One
I've gone into another extension method
which is if default do which means it
assesses the result of this if it's
default I can't say null because we're
dealing with generics and
not everything defaults to not integers
default to zero booleans default false
and so on uh there may be others
and then here's the alternative if what
it means is if this returns default then
do this otherwise just return the
original and down here this is the
default do which takes to this takes the
function and takes the alternative input
and it decides this is a slightly scary
bit of code which is just a generic
version of a null check because again
you can't do a null check on a generic
and what it will do is just assess
whatever this is if it's null then run
the function if it is not null then
simply just return the value itself it's
like a gatekeeper function sitting
between you and the outside world and
it's sort of you're trying to pass and
it'll stand in the way or not depending
on what your what you're carrying
now this is a ridiculously simple
example but I just wanted to keep the
example simple
um and all I'm trying to do is it for
some reason create a a and count of all
the A's the B's and the C's in that
string at the top there I could have
done all sorts of things but I went with
simple because I like simple
this is a fork once again I've heard
these call a few things uh like myself
and
um what it will do is start with a value
and then it's all split off into a
series of prongs as it were of the fork
each prong will act on the original in
ice complete isolation and then a
further function will glue all of the
prongs back together into a single
result
so in my case I'm starting with a string
and then I'm forking this is the joining
function which is a simple sum and here
I am going count all the A's count all
the B's so what I'm going to end up with
in fact is start with a string convert
that to an array of integers via these
three functions here which will be
executed separately on the same input
and then finally take that array of
integers and turn it into a sum
and yet show up to nine
and that's what that looks like
again little extension method
uh attached to everything and this is oh
yeah that's map now that's just to be
clear that is not the same as map in uh
automaper this is like map in I think
it's the way JavaScript uses map which
is like select but it's not like select
okay this is
for some reason this is weirdly easy to
get a mistaken on but map doesn't act
like select in that it turns one thing
into another thing but select acts on
each element of an array separately
map acts on the whole thing
so you can call map on a string and then
this Arrow phone this function will turn
string into whatever else you want if
you fed map an array then this would be
an array or a numerable or whatever it's
the whole object not individual elements
of it so it's one of those funky little
helper functions I find ever so useful
actually no map I think in the
JavaScript world is more like a select
so not like JavaScript
and all it does is convert one thing to
another and I just find it saves me a
lot of space because I don't need an
intermediate variable to store it in or
or anything I can just do this
dot map converted something else and so
this is my Fork though start with the uh
the input whatever that might be and uh
there's the prongs which are my
functions and my join function so
prongs.select bit of Link there so and
then inside the select what I'm saying
is for each prong give it
um this whatever the original this is
and return that result which will give
us an array of whatever's and then call
map to say turn that array into
something so this is a join function
which takes an array of whatever's and
uh turns it into a final single result
to explain
but it doesn't take an awful lot of time
to write one of these things
oh I'm not sure if I need to entirely go
into this in too much detail these days
because this talk is a few years old now
so this has become fairly fairly common
in the uh in the C sharp world now but
just in case here it is so some pattern
recognition it's a pattern matching I
was doing that
um let's start with bank accounts since
that seems to be the go-to example of
how to do these sorts of things we'll
have a standard bank account I'll
inherit off that with a super duper bank
account which has got a Bonus interest
rate and a dodgy bank account which has
got a brown paper bag stuffed with money
probably handed over in a car park for
some reason I'd I when I started this I
usually inserted a reference to
whichever politician was in disgrace
these days at the moment take your pick
plenty to choose from
and I I it's just not even worse it's
it's like shooting was it fishing a
barrel these days okay and there we go
pattern matching I don't know if
everyone's familiar with these uh with
this this stuff now but you can now
switch based on the actual type of an
object which has many sub types so I am
this ba is actually the based on the is
the base type which is bank account and
then under that I'm switching based on
it's a dodgy bank account and then here
it will automatic if it's actually a
Dodger bank account it will
automatically
um wrap it into the correct type and
this variable here can be referenced
inside the the um inside the switch
switch to the right type so imagine just
how much code you'd have to write in
order to do that if I didn't use this
structure it would be quite a lot and it
might well use reflection so this is say
this alone is saving us a colossal
amount of effort
um and yeah you can go a lot further
these days this is I think this is
fairly up to date I don't have a slide
on um on list matching which is the very
latest thing but now you can do all
these sorts of funky switches where you
can like switch on properties like this
in a sort of Json format and you can
really go quite complicated with these
sorts of things it's it's astonishing
just how much code you can write with
this and this this is entirely that
comes from from the functional world
that's where that's what's inspired all
of this
so on the subjects for mutability
can we actually have immutability in C
sharp well here's a few demonstrations
this pretty much is immutable I've got
gets and no sets uh these days actually
you can do init as well uh in its
instead of saying that that'll pretty
much do the same thing in it meaning
um you can set this property when you
instantiate the object and then you
can't change it again which is typically
what I tend to do
um and fine we're only we're not
allowing these to be set in the outside
world and we are at least forcing this
to come in in um in in the Constructor
so that's so mutable that's good
how about now
is that immutable
see I'm not letting anyone um uh change
them I am not I'm forcing it to be done
in the Constructor is this immutable no
no it's not that's a list lists I can't
replace the list with another list
but I can still add and remove and mess
around with the list because that's
lists so that I could go and make it in
a mutable array now it's immutable super
duper uh you can pass a list in all you
like but nope I am making an immutable
array so tough luck now it's not
so that's good
what about now
subclass I don't even know what's inside
class I just made it up that's why but I
am in any case is this immutable
they don't even know but there's the
problem I don't know if every single
class in your whole code base was coded
based on this approach sure ish but then
as soon as you try and throw in
something that's come out and you get
some sort of third-party coding
structure it all goes out the window
because once again we return to I don't
even know
so this is this is one of my more
controversial opinions on this subject
I think immutability in C sharp is a
pipe dream
I mean fundamentally they're not going
to change the language so that we can't
support everything going backwards they
want it to be so that pretty much any
older older code always tends to run in
the environment so they're not just
going to sweeping make a change that
will just suddenly make everything
immutable because it break half of the
code in the world probably more than
that so
my Approach is just pretend
which seems absurd but you'd be
surprised how much good code you can
write that way just pretend everything
is immutable write code as if that were
true now it is unfortunate you can't
enforce it but that's just the way it is
this is C Sharp it is always going to
support multiple paradigms that's not
going to change they're not going to
drop support for object-oriented coding
so we just have to do the best we can
and yeah you can put stuff like this in
where you can have compiler warnings
like your nullable enable that's pretty
good but you know that's nice I do
enable that but um once again we really
it's only a compiler warning at least
the last time I looked it was I don't
think it'll actually break the code and
if you want to override it you can put
an exclamation whereas uh there's
somewhere uh there we go yeah uh where
they put it
I've lost it but there's an exclamation
in there somewhere ah there it is there
it is yeah the exclamation is there to
say yes I'm a grown-up yes I know do it
anyway uh which does exist in some
functional languages as well I think get
F sharp everything is immutable by
default but you can make mutable
um types but you have to specifically
create so you know that's that's not an
entirely wrong thing to do but you know
this is nice but I honestly I find the
just pretend approach Works an awful lot
better and you can enable it uh globally
like that
how do we tell this guy how old this
talk is now
um right
now
oh a class oh yes so yes there's the
init type I've already mentioned that in
it I do use that quite a lot I find that
quite handy that's that's more of a
that's the closest I get to actually
enforcing immutability
um so it just means I can just
instantiate a new object like this
and then if I try to change one of those
properties later to something else that
actually will break it that'll actually
cause a compiler error and it won't even
build so that I use I use I would
recommend using that pretty widely
there we go and Records uh we I don't
know if everyone's familiar with records
now records are one of my favorite
things since the other favorite things
that they introduced but since link and
pattern matching records is my other
favorite thing
um that is again something that has come
around to help support the functional
Paradigm because it enables you to
easily create a new object from an L1
which is exactly what we tend to use in
the non-record world when writing an
update function we wouldn't update the
object we would literally create a new
one copy over each and every property
one after the other and Records just
allows us to skip all of that because
now with records you can just say with
tell it what the one change that you
want to make is and then you'll get a
new object back with just that type now
I believe as of now this is actually
still
um a reference type but I believe there
are changes coming in to allow it to be
um a pass by value as well but I'm not
quite sure where we are on that this
this as it happens is just a silly bit
of code to tell me which property of
this you want to update and then give
give me uh give me a new one with the
one changed property and maybe a bit of
parsing or whatever as appropriate
so currying I did say I would talk about
currying and here it is hurrying nothing
to do with delicious delicious Indian
food
um sadly but right this is a
hypothetical example of currying sort of
that's just a normal Arrow function an
ad at one a plus b so if I give it 10
and 20 I get back 30. simple
um at least one of my daughters could
manage this
um mentioning her name's Katie
uh and but what if it was a courage
function what if by waving my magic wand
I could make currying a thing that
happened by default in C sharp which it
doesn't it does in F sharp not in C
sharp so it's a bit imagine for a moment
I have just given it one parameter the
function requires two does anyone happen
to know what will happen if this is a
curried function
anyone to take a guess
okay well there is a rule of thumb in
functional programming if there is a
question the answers functions and that
roughly holds true
so if a curried function you pass in one
of the parameters of two
what you'll get back is
there we go what you'll get back is a
function
and the function will be equivalent to
the original function accepting that
everywhere where parameter one was
referenced is now replaced with the
actual value that you gave
so
when I have an ad with two properties
two parameters
and I give it one
effectively what I've turned into is an
add 10 function
so now this is still an ad but the one
property has been replaced simply with
10.
that's what carrying is
and strictly speak this is true carrying
never mind
um
there's also partial application where
so currying truecarrying is where you do
the functions one after the other so if
you um if you have five parameters then
you'd have to like carry it about five
times to actually get a result out
there's also partial application where
you can just apply them in clusters like
you know I'll do two parameters then
three but frankly I'm blurring the lines
horribly because I'm not really
interested enough to go to the entire
the purity of of the the some of these
definitions but anyway can we do this in
C sharp is probably the question that's
uh that's occurring to folks now the
answer is well the short answer is no
ish
uh the long answer is yes kind of
um first off carrying scratch are quite
easy that looks like this now note that
there are two arrows in each of these
okay Arrow one Arrow two there are two
arrows these are Arrow functions that
return another arrow function so yes
this is curry does this have uses some
uh I sometimes throw things like this
together to kind of save myself a little
bit of um a little bit of code noise or
or maybe to make something look a bit
more descriptive when I'm putting
together a big chain of functions
something like that let's add it uses
but unlike in the F sharp world we can't
just arbitrarily then go and apply both
parameters we've got to strictly do them
in order
there is an alternative that's that's
more like what we call partial
application which is roughly the same
concept so this once again returning to
Doctor Who I told you might be back
again yay
um this is a really generic version
another a rather crude
um
uh parser for a csb where it was split
by by line first split Again by
um by by field so by line will be new
line by field it'll be a comma like you
see there
um maybe do some trimming and selecting
and then of the array of arrays will
then go through the whole lot and return
one of the fields from it okay so it's
doing an awful lot of stuff that's
that's a fairly complicated little
function and I'm going to pass in um
three parameters to make it happen a
string a car uh and an INT
if I wanted to do partial application I
could use it like this
so I'm using an extension method I'll
show you in a minute
um called apply so apply means give me
back a function which is the equivalent
of the original but with these
parameters filled in so that is my kind
of my carrying my partial application so
first off start with the original
function and apply a new line and comma
so what I've now got here is something
which will take a CSV content it will
split it by line it will split it by by
column and then
um it still requires you to tell me
first off which field do you want and
then actually give me the string because
I don't have it yet
then I could call it again I could I
could partially apply this one and say I
want the zeroth field which is the story
code because every doc two story has a
story code so what I've now got is a
function which takes a string which is a
csb and then does all of that business
it splits it splits it and then gets the
zeroth item and here we can call the
pars here and differently apply it give
it a one which now means I've got
something that will take the CSV split
it split it give me the story title so
I've created two different functions
with an awful lot of functionality but
I've actually only written one function
there's still only one pass function
everything else is just kind of a
functional equivalent of trying to give
it many ways to be used kind of like
trying to turn into different shapes to
go in the different holes as it were now
how do you actually do this
Ah that's pretty ugly not gonna lie but
that's how you do it
so uh once again this if you were to use
this this is something you show up to
the back of your code base and try
really hard to forget but this is
roughly what it's done again two arrows
Arrow Arrow this is an arrow function
returning another arrow function and it
is taking the original Arrow function
now it'll only be possible to apply this
to
um funks because you cannot hang
um
a function called can't have an
extension method in C sharp so that's
one limitation you'll have to take your
your function and store it in a funk
somewhere and then having done that we
call this and it Returns the new
function with some of the parameters
coming from the new arrow that you're
creating and some coming from the
original uh call which days sort of
stored in in memory as a reference until
such time as um uh you actually collapse
this into a value and the other problem
here is you have to create one of these
for every combination of variables going
out to variables uh coming in so you
might have to write a lot of these none
of them are terribly complicated this
won't take a lot of time to do but
you'll have to create one version of
this for everything you know five to one
five to two five to three and so on
so if okay
so this is a typical flow in a in a
functional function
start with one thing first opportunity
you get split it into a list of things
of some description uh this this is why
a lisp had its name it was the was it
list processing language because
functional works best when you have
turned something into an array else
whatever and you are applying list based
operations to it uh maybe do some
wearing maybe do some selecting to turn
it into a different type and then
finally this is the last bit aggregating
aggregating is the art of turning many
things into one thing
and this is the bit that probably tends
to loot a lot of folks uh when they're
trying to move when they're when they're
trying to move away from the
object-oriented approaches well we have
a whole load built into C sharp already
uh this is an example of what you would
do in the old odd Victorian world to
um aggregate something you'd uh maybe
I'll put a string builder in because I'm
I've been doing this for a bit I know
about the don't and Pen strings in a
loop thing if you don't know about that
ask ask a friend and uh I'll loop around
append lines I also need to put an if in
there to say well if it's the last one
don't append uh a comma to uh and then
eventually we'll get a list of all the
um all these story titles with a comma
accepting on the last one and some new
lines so super that's object oriented
code
that's the functional version
yeah be a little facetious here
string.join if you don't know what
string dot would join use it today it's
brilliant it's one of my favorite
functions in the whole of C sharp but
yeah it gets around that problem of um
how what do you do with the last item
because this does all that for you
get the idea that is an example of
aggregation but yeah the slightly more
grown-up version of it uh so let's take
a list of um this is these are objects
representing Doctor Who stories so I've
got my code my title my rating that's my
personal rating of whether I liked it or
not first dialect story is good the
sensor rights is terrible and you get
the idea a number of episodes because in
the old days Doctor Who was all serials
many episodes per story and the number
of missing episodes because there are
two date 97 missing episodes if any of
you have them I'd be awfully grateful if
you'd if you'd hand them over especially
if it's Fury from the deep I'd quite
like to see that one
um but anyway and I want to put some
sort of report together of comparing say
number of episodes to number of missing
episodes per season
now of course the sums sum is another
form of aggregation exists that's that's
a link method some is good uh there's
average which calls it average I think
is actually a mean because then like
three kinds of averages or something
like that but fine it exists I don't
think there's a way to do mediums easily
in in C sharp uh
that but this is the grown-up version
aggregate
uh it was I am astonished by how many
people don't know this exists but it's
been in C sharp since a very very long
time it's it seems to be one of those
great unknown things of C sharp almost
and I will carry on talking about it and
until people's tell me that that this is
old stuff now but this is brilliant
aggregate is incredible I use it a lot
and what it means is
uh it's not unlike a select statement in
that we apply it to an array or an
innumerable rather and it'll apply to
each island to minute separately
um but here we start with a starting
state I'm using a tuple uh of zero zero
meaning uh the number of missing
episodes in here and the number of
actual episodes here and then you give
it a function after that the function is
this is the running total so far and
this is the current item this is like
your X in an actual select statement
and this slot is give me a new running
total based on the old running total and
the current item and then it'll apply
that to every item in the entire
enumerable and then finally what you'll
get is is literally just
whatever the final version of this is so
the first time this runs it'll be zero
zero so we'll go into here that zero
zero that's the current item which is
Earthly child four episodes non-missing
um so this will be zero and this will be
four so this will return a new Tuple of
four zero then it'll execute again and
it'll be uh the Dalek seven episodes and
I'm missing
um which the current then this will be
four zero because it's already run once
this will be seven zero you get the idea
and so on and so forth all the way to
the end
this is I think the last item I'm going
to introduce to you so this is something
that I used to do quite a lot when I
worked for an American company
um I I'm British as you can probably
tell and um and as you guys probably
mostly know we do indeed talk about the
weather an awful lot it is a thing that
we do
um and I would ask my American
colleagues what the weather is like and
they would say that the temperature is
100 degrees outside and I think 100
degrees that's the boiling point of
water
um my goodness that sounds quite serious
uh but of course they're talking
Fahrenheit which is used by America and
I use celsius which is used by everyone
else
um and uh so the conversion is deduct 32
multiplied by 5 divided by nine
something of that sort of course it is
so one point is I've got a series of
operations here start with a thing do a
thing get the new value do another thing
get a new value do another thing yeah
um it's like a relay race of operations
one after the other now I could store
these intermediate variables if I wanted
to make this more functional and that's
great but then I've created all these
intermediate variables
um and before any anyone points out yes
you could all just put this one great
big line but then I would have no
demonstration so imagine swapping these
out for um some more complex operations
I am keeping life simple by giving you
this example but how could I do this in
a much better way
well this is an object called identity
here I've heard this called a few things
um it's an identity of type T this is a
class and here we go it's got one
property which is simply value
um you put a bit of syntactic sugar in
here so you can just turn things into an
identity or not or to be honest I often
just create extension methods and that's
fine think of identity as thing in a box
thing in the box that's all it is this
box got a thing and it's a t so it could
be anything I don't know what it doesn't
matter but it's a thing in a box
and there we go there's my extension
method and I'll create a function
hanging off it called bind her disc
called a few things too but bind is as
good as anything for now and this is not
unlike my map function from earlier
um and what this does is take a function
which turns old thing to new thing most
of the time in that previous example I
think it'd be decimals to decimals but
it could be decimal to string oh who
knows what it doesn't really matter but
thing to thing and so what this function
does is take the old box
pull the thing out do a thing to it pop
it in the new box send it off
and then the next guy will do the exact
same thing it's a relay race of of
functions each uh each person takes the
old item does a thing passes it on and
each time it's a new box with the old
one effectively chucked away the moment
it was done because everything is
transitive in in functional and then
what can end up with something like this
now look there's my um there's my code
functions they're back see they have
their uses
um and so that looks pretty good no
intermediate variables everything is
immutable
each of those
um values exists for a moment and it's
chucked away so that's great uh
technically this will um probably maybe
have some Savings in one of those large
complex object because it's basically
chucked away the moment you've used it
that's great so this is a simple example
of what's called a monad
uh in case anyone ever felt they didn't
know what they were there they are
don't be looking them upon Wikipedia by
the way uh the technical definitions are
really quite terrifying I've been doing
this for years and even I don't
understand the technical definitions but
you won't know what a monad is relay
race take a thing do a thing pass it on
that's it it's a way of chaining
functions there's a bit more to it but
this is good enough I'm an engineer I
need an engineer's description
so there is another form of monad
because there's a load of different
monads for different purposes there's
loads on I only use probably two or
three because that's all I need at least
in the C sharp World Haskell's got a ton
but I don't use Haskell I'm a C sharp
developer
um but this one's maybe now this is
similar to my previous one the identity
one but there's a difference okay
there's a difference
um
first this deals with the problem of
what if something explodes what if
there's an error stuff like that it
deals with that problem for you so we've
got some sort of get person function
here which goes away maybe it does a
database operation doesn't really matter
and what if that returns null well if
that return to null then on the existing
system this this will just explode
because null reference exception the the
so-called was it million dollar mistake
um I I don't want that to explode I want
that to be handled I want the maybe the
the the bind function to be smart and
handle that problem and when each little
bind to be like a a safe environment to
run the function but not be affected by
it
so
this is another one of those places
where I I know about dozen names for
this particular structure but I'm making
an abstract class called maybe again
it's a type T and it's got a value
meaning I've got a thing in a box just
the same
and I'll inherit of it twice once has
just I've also heard this called sum
maybe I've also heard called option so
you may hear different names
um
and this means it works there was a
thing the thing was taken in the
function was executed something was
returned out it was good and this is
nothing meaning didn't work it aired or
um a null came back or something but the
point is that if it's a nothing it is
nothing and I'm just going to replace
that with the default
and there's my more complicated bind
so now I'll you do a switch to say okay
look at the item you've just handed me
did it actually contain something as in
was it a just store or something or
whatever uh was it not null if it was
something and it was not null in that
case run the new function and then take
the result put it in a new maybe box and
send it on its way all other
circumstances result in just ain't gonna
do a thing I'm just going to return to
nothing and if anything fails it'll also
return to nothing if there's a it's a
Catch catches
the best analogy to this I've ever read
was on Scott blashian's website it's a
very good website F-sharp Fun and Profit
it's not just refsharp developers
there's a lot of good theory articles on
there too
um but he called it a railway orientated
architecture I believe and so the idea
is that you've got two railway tracks
running along like this and there's a
set of points each point is a function
and then it'll execute each function and
the top track is the the something the
happy path and if at any point something
fails you switch tracks and then just
Glides to the end without doing another
thing
so if I just there we go if I blast back
to this so in my example here so this is
now a maybe this bind will check the
inside of the maybe it's something it is
a personal ID what 12 whatever 12 means
and uh it'll then fair enough I will
execute that function now the person two
maybe it's a null or maybe it throws an
error who knows it doesn't matter what
the point is it doesn't work in which
case you'll get nothing back so this
bind executes it has a look inside the
box and it says actually the type of
this is a nothing I'm not going to do it
so this function here is not executed
nor any of these what I get back is a
null the last function that was executed
was this one
so the whole concept of worrying about
null checks and try catches goes away
it's now baked into the structure of
this this binded maybe system
so basically no more errors anymore in
theory I mean you could probably find
new and creative ways to add them in but
it is an awful lot harder you're going
to work for your errors this is an
alternative it's called either
um it it's
um again I've heard a few names but it
has a right and a left that's there so
it's usually defined the the right is
the the happy path the the right hand of
Justice or whatever and the left the
left hand of Darkness the left hand of
evil as it often is in many cultures is
is where it didn't work so in my case
I'm just giving it radically different
things so I'm saying there's a value
here and here there's uh nothing a
default and I'm actually capturing the
exception so in the case of this one
when I get to the end of my chain of
functions I can examine it and then not
only do I have a check already baked in
to say did it work or not but if it
didn't I'll actually catch the exception
and I can display that to screen or log
it or whatever I need to do but I
haven't actually broken the order of
operations
you've slightly modified two either now
in in production to be honest I tend to
merge these two together so I create
like a three-state uh monad which isn't
exactly strict functional um uh
Theory but it works for me so I have
like something nothing error because
those are the three states I tend to
always need to check after every
operation did it work did I get
something did it throw an error and that
means I just do a switch operation
afterwards to collapse that possible
three-state thing into a one-state thing
it's like it's like shreddinger's object
you get this box uh there might be a
dead cat or it might not be a dead cat
but you can check but only at the moment
you check does it matter otherwise you
can simply pass it on without opening it
so are there any libraries which exist
in nuget for doing functional yes there
are language X is probably the largest
and most mature of all of them
um language X is a is a good one if you
if you want to now personally I don't
use it it's not because it's not good I
think it is good but I think that it's
so simple to write your own that largely
that's what I do
and also it's good for learning the
theory which again is what I like to do
so I can personalize to exactly my taste
but if if you just want to use language
X go for it more power to you there is
nothing wrong with it there are others
but this is the main one probably
and that's what the language X version
of Sir of my monad looks like except it
calls it map instead of bind well
strictly speaking map and bind to
different things which they they
actually respect inside language x i i
kind of ignore the difference difference
but when I'm not going too deep into
Theory
finally
further material there is an excellent
book by Enrico buenano published by
Manning it's in the second edition now
this is an excellent book
um that's functional programming and C
sharp that was one of the things that
put me down this path originally
um there are there is a talk there is
one by pacts by I hope I'm saying this
right Vishnu angoro
um uh one day he'll be in the audience
he'll be like chucking stuff up he said
no it's nothing to say my name
but I I hope it's not too bad but uh
that's that's pretty good although I
like the the one I know book is is
really quite excellent there is a talk
which is actually what the first
introduction I ever got to functional
programming by Kathleen dollar uh that
was done at NDC Oslo many years ago it's
still on YouTube if you were to be able
to do magic and turn the camera around
on that video you'd see me stir gorping
with uh uh or the nice talk there are a
couple of pluralsight talks and there is
Scott lashen's website which I do
recommend even if you don't plan to do
F-sharp and and then learn your Haskell
for great good I mean yes if you want to
go all the way uh you can sure you pick
a pascal and also as my book I have a
book
uh yay my book
um it's not quite as as probably not as
as in-depth and pure to the functional
Paradigm as the uh the buenano book is
which is an excellent book still I I I'm
more the the Silly Fun Uncle of the
programming world and it is full of
terrible dad jokes I'm just warning you
I keep expecting the editors to take
them out and they're not doing it so
I'll keep putting them in
so that is not incidentally my animal uh
I don't know what the animal's gonna be
apparently there is a secret cabal of
animal choosers somewhere deep in the
dark depths of O'Reilly and they will
descend from on high when it's
publication day and then I will know my
animal and knowing my luck it'll
probably be something repulsive like a
naked mole rat or something but I I will
I will cope with whatever I get uh this
um barcode by the way O'Reilly gave me
that um it'll give you I think some
months free on there on their website so
the pre-release version is available
there's nine chapters of the book I
think available on there at the present
um I'm currently writing chapter 13. so
yeah it's fresh it's thought to be
coming out probably in the summer
um although probably the only people
ever buy it'll be like my parents and
anyone that I um give a 20 pound note to
take a copy from me but still if you're
interested there's my book
oh I can take a short breathe does
anyone have any questions at this point
odd silence
not sure if good or bad
okay memory management you're curious
about how I deal with memory management
okay so there is
um there is a widely held opinion that
functional programming is not good on
memory management it tends to use more
memory that is not itself is true
functional programming does use more
memory compared to object-oriented
Alternatives
um if if memory usage and speed are your
absolute main 100 priority you probably
don't want to do this
because you know like
an object oriented code is always going
to be slightly faster and slightly more
memory efficient generally speaking but
the difference isn't that much most of
the time
I've done a whole load of checks and
if you compare how long the function
runs object orientated compared to
functional uh it's it's like there's a
bit of difference but then you throw in
something like a file read it's like
this much difference
so the difference gen for most cases is
insignificant compared to the problems
of read a file or go away over and do an
HTTP request
very large amount of data you can use
like generators so you'll need to have
like a little piece of ground
okay generate okay with python you have
generators and I'm afraid I'm not
familiar with those uh
okay lazy okay well effectively okay
it's gonna instantiate something in a
lazy manner we can't I mean innumerables
have that of course let enumerables are
lazy I'm not sure how much else we can
do in the I mean we are still
constrained by the limits of the c-sharp
language so on this I'm going to have to
plead ignorance but um the only thing I
would say though is avoid recursion I do
joke about recursion but yeah it's not a
joke that stuff's horrible
um it'll explode fast in in the c-sharp
world but um f sharp you can actually do
recursion safely it has something in
place which if you look in the
intermediate languages uh hidden while
loop but
um basically but no I'm afraid I I wish
I could provide you with more than that
but um
uh but no I I I don't know I'm not I'll
look into generators and maybe I'll I'll
write something up on that
sure sure yeah
does anyone else does anyone else have
any further question oh I have two
sir
uh I noticed you were using X unit is
that more friendly no X unit so I was
using X unit yes uh no not particularly
I just like it uh I just happen to like
X unit that's that's just a preference
uh I also quite like fluent Expressions
uh the fluid assertion sorry fluid
assertions just like it it looks
friendly
no it's got nothing to do with
functional not functional that's just
what I like to use
so
okay how much are you talking about a
null co-listing so in how do I balance
um null coalescing with full monads well
this is where you get more into the art
than the science of these things but uh
if it's if it's really simple then I'd
probably just throw a quick null
coalesce if if there's any number of
operations whatsoever Full Moon ads it
is I have a little bit of a preference
to be honest for literally writing
everything as an arrow function and
never putting a body on any function
ever but probably people at my work
would just throw things at me if I tried
doing that so uh go and have a look at
my answers to the adventure code if you
want to see me going all 100 as far as I
can go but uh yeah that's my rough rule
of thumb it's simple no Co less more
than that moan as it is or if there's
any possibility of an exception
happening if there's a chance it might
throw then we're going back into the
monad because the monad's like a nice
safe environment to let things explode
isn't it so if I'm doing a database
operation and usually most of my return
types in my uh on my any database
operations is actually usually maybe or
whatever it is maybe even you it's awful
when you get into async it's like May uh
May task of maybe of a new
of donkeys or whatever but still it does
we all know what that does it's sort of
unwrapping I've done wrap one at a time
though but
anymore for any more
going once
go oh there we
do I use any other container mode ads in
fact uh as I say I actually use one
which is kind of a mix of maybe and
option or uh either uh so minus three
states as I say uh the the something the
nothing and the error which is not
strict functional
um Paradigm correct but it works and it
does everything I want to do so by and
large I use that I have been known to
use a reader
um
but I don't even use that very often to
be honest largely an estate moan I'd
have used those once or twice lordly
though my little my funky uh jury rigged
three-state monad is the one I use
so
um I I got all that in the book if
you're interested I'll have a chat with
me afterwards but uh yeah any more for
any more so
validations
uh the the fluent
um yeah the validation put your mind of
fluid validations would I recommend that
I haven't actually used that myself but
I think it's the same guys that use
fluent expression affluent assertions
and I know people who use that and love
it I actually know before they brought
that out I actually had a colleague who
tried wanted to use fluent assertions in
production code because he loved it that
much and until everyone started throwing
their shoes at him but um yes I
definitely would I probably should pick
that up myself and it's probably just
sheer laziness I haven't but yeah
absolutely fluent assertions is lovely
and by extension also uh yeah we're
starting to lose people now but I'm
still happy to take questions
anyone else got any questions
going once
going twice death solved thank you very
much